hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to I may die now this is a
platforming game that probably and I say
probably because I don't know for sure
but probably is going to be rage
inducing and difficult in a lonely
floating island there was someone who
lived alone he never met anyone the only
interesting thing he could see was the
darkness of the void that surrounded his
Island why did he stare into the
Island how did he have an island anyway
oh oh wait I got ah I see okay now I
know it's probably gonna be bad is
because I have to use a controller for I
don't have to I could use a keyboard but
something tells me I don't want it what
a quaint little treehouse why did I need
to build a treehouse when I had plenty
of Island land to build upon because
it's cuter hello Oh time to stare into
the dark void the emptiness inside my
soul really resonates on this precipice
we're like I imagine it's just complete
death but oh no nevermind I imagine it's
sunshine and rainbows beneath me oh oh
geez how exactly do bottomless pits work
no one ever knows no one's ever returned
I just missed that money what's the
point though what's the point of getting
money if I don't know if I'm ever gonna
return to my home oh this is adorable
what am i a little bear that's cute oh
look at me oh look at me stick to a wall
and jump to reach the top like Super
Meat Boy oh that's nice
mom always said look both ways before
you cross oh and also try to avoid the
murder spikes Oh trust you me I'm very
familiar with murderous spikes given
that Springs are quite literally the
only thing that doesn't want you for
dinner down here enjoy ah never mind
enjoy the spring not the other thing we
all aren't you adorable okay
y'see to pay a fee sound what is it
sound like a baby it's just like that
game where you where you said the floor
was lava but only way more painful
okay I'm so cute but I don't know if
that's good mmm something something just
rubs me the wrong way about all of this
wait no what they move was too bad I'm
good at this oh that is just unfair you
can't pull the spikes on the wall
especially the moving spikes that's just
unfair all right
so far so good box is good for climbing
pushing and entertaining cats aha I'm
dead did that entertain hat apparently
not all right Boing okay
Yahoo indeed I don't like this oh thank
you for that no I did it again and jump
now okay okay yeah yeah oh yeah I'm fine
okay yeah that was not enough Joe okay
it was enough jump just barely enough
yawn pinch the fading floor is 50%
geological mystery 50% evil deathtrap
all right here we go amazing oh that's a
tight squeeze made it okay so we just
got to get to oh I missed a coin yeah my
completionist nature is gonna rebel
against me but frankly I don't care so
many eyes why why couldn't you fall into
the adorable cave of love bunnies watch
out they shoot where's the adorable
cabled love boy hey don't blink at me
ah ah you got targeting systems don't
you you got good old targeting systems
they call those eyes but I call them
targeting system
okay fine we're fine we're fine miss me
I think oh you didn't need to miss me I
miss myself no boy okay we're good we're
good
Oh collided into it directly dude my
birdly okay see ya see how you miss me
and I don't miss me because I'm not bad
[ __ ] at least I know that they don't
earn me if I touch him aye aye aye aye
I fight I never in my life wanted to be
anywhere
what right there okay nails bad okay
good then just when you thought it
couldn't get any worse you discover the
wonders of Angry cyclopean bird or worms
put that on a bumper sticker cuz that's
amazing okay okay alright we're fine
because I need to Boeing I don't know
but they're Boeing's okay we've got that
yeah we turn fright and mildly French to
be able to run away faster no okay well
that was stupid of me
it's BuChE BuChE BuChE BuChE ah this is
bad ski Oh Nelly me in my belly
oh I should have jumped well I should
have jumped there too but that's that's
besides the point a Stein law hand hand
Stein law hand hand oh that's amazing is
that a hand with the twiddly fingers
okay I'm gonna assume that oh man your
fingers are tender yeah you you you
shouldn't be slamming your fingers down
if they're that not nimble hobo inky
alright so mr. Stein law hand hand what
why you didn't Tommy Stein longhand hand
out a shooting Judy I I okay don't do
that again
whatever come on come at me bro
sacrifice another one of your amazing
hands nice hand point how about another
one how about the other one are you
gonna shoot a shoe dii oh okay you're
gonna botch you're about to lose a hand
forever I don't know if you
blink ok well that's sad for you
blowing blowing blowing look this is bow
okay I panicked for Noah I did it twice
I didn't know you're gonna do that the
music's real hype about this Asher I'm
glad that it's hyping up this situation
to its maximum potential as Huo a death
come at me bro come at me bro
hey you missed me wink all right give me
your other hand
or shoot me with your eyes oh yeah
mistake one of those would have worked
and you chose the wrong one because I
got a butt of steel I got like Kirby and
stone form right on your stone and like
brittle bone it whoa you have to do the
factory they say the only thing worse
than a worm in your Apple is half a worm
oh oh I thought I was gonna smear like
in that image that's horrifying
oh that's horrifying okay how's it going
on here hello hello friends okay ah you
didn't tell me that you were gonna stop
there I should have looked and I would
have seen that you were gonna stop there
but then again I don't look with my eyes
because I'm too busy talking about how
great I am
which I am very grave uh yeah all right
we're good we're good
hmm that's a narrow gap you want me to
squeeze in there because I've got some
pretty good squeezing abilities oh oh I
see you want me to yum Oh missed one I
gotta go back I've never watched all I
know is the memes from it oh shoot deep
I shouldn't have gone deep I shouldn't
have gone there I am dumb that is lava
disclaimer the lava is actually
extremely hot especially when you burn
your balls off
boopy boopy boopy okay we're in yeah
this is a portal please note that any
appearance of dangers merely a device to
enhance your testing experience haha
that's a reference oh man
are you funny I don't like that at all
this is precarious oh that's what I want
my last words to be as I fall to my
death and then die oh here's my timing
there we go okay this is almost my
timing okay
ski alright we did that alright used to
access [ __ ] your point key oh yeah you
know who Boinky me poin key on you not
on you actually that's the opposite yeah
okay alright good think they give me
check this was super meatboy they
wouldn't give me any checkpoints oh okay
good take that Wow that thing was not
very fragile if my hand can but blast a
stone hand off of a boss bad boy maybe
maybe I should have just been but
blasting these saw blades maybe that
would have worked oh okay well alright
then it's a it's the things from Mario
but now instead of fire their death
their patented ball slicers oh you block
the shots what is this I got the chest
it made no no huh okay well that is a
portal doom gotta go at it well that a
portal of nowhere apparently Oh dopey
alright dokey
you can't shoot me if I jump oh yeah you
see how I dodge that by not actually
dodging it and just hoping that it
wouldn't hit me yeah that's my strategy
I don't like that's a tight fit sir a
smaller-sized this was not the correct
way but I'm gonna go this move right now
ah
Channel Dwarfs - that was my first
mistake Italy Italy
oddly deadly no last coin why am i
greedy
I was completely optional also I've
completely ignored the fact that its
baby screams cute little baby
air that's dying a whole lot you know I
like to make goofy noises when i'm about
i I'm afraid that is gonna be my last
one actual last words what I'm like when
I die stupidly which is obviously what's
gonna happen I'm trying to say something
profound like life is not the live that
I did and banging I'm dead but instead
of come out this is ha see you didn't
shoot because you were scared of me
I used to be a gummy bear like you oh
I'm a gummy bear but then I took an oak
an oak what's it this good newark i was
chucking my own spit cuz i realized what
an earth was okay alright don't arc me
bro
don't hurt a Heuer to me bro yeah that's
a good organ okay that's a gherkin irken
need to that see you don't need to do
that how do you how do you avoid that
which kind of how do you avoid that
which cannot be killed
how do you kill that which should not be
named
where's the part when I need them see
okay there we go yeah jump over that and
then jump over that and then narrow but
I can fit yeah yeah yeah I'm dead is
what this guy just sang that Chuck poot
well this is gonna be bad well also bad
oh I hate well don't like this this this
is a doozy oh I can welcome well if I
just go one for one blanca on these bad
boys well yeah I'm gonna go one for one
welp nup to furs to one foot one foot
that [ __ ] of Blanc you with my blood
plaster puts hidden well yep one for one
I'll get him by sure numb well yep I
sure did didn't I there was no need to
actually employ any skill in that matter
I I brewed forced my way right
[Music]
don't like that at all at all at all at
all at all I'm gonna die my eyes have
never been this open in my entire
existence yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yah yeah yah yah yah
Chabad what if I stick to the wall
wouldn't that be a smart stratagem that
way I can oh yeah that would that would
be smart yeah that'd be really smart if
I did that but I didn't do that because
I'm dumb
yeah that's the easy way that's the
pansy baby easy way I'm gonna do it the
hard markiplier way the way that you
know you should do it the way that brave
boys do it
brave man cuz I'm a man but I'm a brave
man yeah okay well if I close my eyes
and look away it doesn't really help my
situation does indecisiveness will kill
me I did better the first time that
night I could see you I didn't see you
is that one okay big one alright ah you
think I don't got this I got okay well
yeah fine again if I look away and I try
to reach everybody I'm not even looking
at the screen why am I not looking at
the screen half the time III haha but
you thought you could wart me but you
could not all right but you can Oh
nailed it I'm the better what is bad you
have no idea how expensive it was to
install those flamethrowers well then
why did you do it you know you know I
didn't ask for this just cuz you spent
on me that was toasty just cuz you spent
money on me it doesn't mean that I need
to be responsible for your don't I I
didn't see you because I was too
bothered looking at the flames well if I
just run right into the fire and hope
and pray that it doesn't burn me I don't
think
wow you are not forgiving are you why
did I go why did I go why did I go fine
oh I said it's fine and I didn't need to
go and then what do I do i freakin go oh
wow now I'm getting dosed this [ __ ] you
okay well posted on both sides
well I touched you before it didn't kill
me I I mentally noted that it was like
oh if I touch that it doesn't kill me
that's a that's a good mental note to
have oh I don't like you I could have
gone why didn't I go it was completely
clear and empty I'm going okay I'm going
I'm not going I'm going okay here we go
see this is better I just be done need
to sack up and get out the door with
more oh you did it just enough to be
able to fool me yeah no that's just
unfair see that's just unfair you're
being unfair to me and I don't like it
did you start there and then you you
I forgot you keep going but not that
time oh and then I jump right into the
area that it's gonna burn me who's gonna
be the one who's gonna I said oh I
saying it shalt be it is the one why am
I not done yet oh my god
be careful those guided-missile I wasn't
paying attention so you know you don't
be where the guy did miss not so bad I
can deal with the guy did bring analysis
that's not what I didn't know that it
was gonna be like that I didn't know
when you said guided missiles it was
actually gonna track me what do you
think I am just a genius here yeah no
this is impossible
okay apparently not fairly it's not
impossible but it was totally possible
and I just did it yeah
I hate you have so many questions
ah come on my opportunities are being
forwarded by the I why did I jump
why it's like it predicts what I'm good
at what stupid maneuver I'm gonna do cuz
uh you know what maybe that's the
strategy I'm just gonna keep going I
made it apparently yeah all right am I
not done yet what is with you what is
with you get some let's get some the I
thing you got red dry eyes get clear
eyes that's it that's well Musel alright
okay well if I jump into him I would
have been fine if I had oak duty with
the arrow god yes I didn't even know
there was an arrow it was just falling
downward well if I don't jump enough
it's not gonna do do nothing yeah why
didn't you these if you did last time
jump
why arrow arrow they put that arrow just
to make sure you get properly dict over
not just a little bit dict over but you
get like royal edict over you get the
Royal Dickens treatment blue no I'm not
clear I'm clear I'm clear eyes I had
that been then I lost it cuz I was too I
could it closed my eyes didn't I wait I
just realized I closed my eyes before I
died with your face nailed it
alright final nail that's just unfair
I've been through easily ten of these
levels haven't I haven't died don't miss
me
oh well I was so worried about a missile
I totally forgot about the fact that
there's frickin normal ass spike owes
spike Oh psycho
oh well that's also
problem miss me oh come on
I'm so not cool no I didn't get the last
card I hate you how many levels were in
this goddamn Factory I've been through
like 13 of you I've been trying to end
this goddamn episode oh really that's
how you're gonna spray and pray well
don't worry I got me you don't worry
about me let me worry about Blanc all
right I'm a pro I'm a pro I'm not a pro
but you know here I go that's not well
this that's gonna bite me in the right
house well not you but the eye
stop stop stop oh there we go
Oh TRO serous I don't know what is that
what are you doing that's not cool at
all that's the opposite of cool so yeah
oh I just got a stroke well god damn it
I was very obviously oh I guess I just
got to survive you huh well it don't be
easy don't you worry about blank let me
worry about blank and by blank I mean
worry about my own ass okay I guess it's
just surfing well hand-grenade is really
you're gonna be it's a bullet hell it's
fine it's fine I got this you see how I
got this watch corner strap well did oh
he gets energy every time I die that's
unfair
keep pumping out those for energy no not
there
ouuuu you did that on porpoise oh oh
come on number got your number I've got
your number
aha I got your number off the bathroom
wall someone said to call me for a good
time and this is obviously not a good
time but I'm having a good time making
an ass out of you yeah try that try that
you think that's gonna work the answer
is No
Oh totally intended that was not
intended you know near mess with me
you're not need to mess with you I
thought you were going to corrupt me oh
you fell to pieces [ __ ]
all right thank you oh that was the free
version oh that was really cool
that was tough I got admit that was
tough yeah there's the fridge oh there's
more chapters so anyway that is I may
die and the answer is yes I will die
because frickin five thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought of this down in the comments
below I will provide a link to this game
if you want to play for yourself try to
beat my score in the number of deaths
that I had and thank you everybody for
watching also we are going on tour in
exactly two weeks the first show that we
got going on in Louisville Kentucky will
be here very soon so if you haven't
gotten a ticket yet check out the link
in the description below markiplier calm
or check out the little widget down
there that shows you where your nearest
is a lot of them are starting to sell
out so get tickets while you can thank
you everybody so much
I will see you
[Music]